hundreds of people headed out to
container park today to
celebrate easter marking the first big
event the park has held since the
pandemic started
that's where we find 8 news now reporter
victoria saha live with more on
how families were celebrating victoria
hey sasha well this was the perfect
excuse for families to come out and
enjoy the beautiful weather
and take part in the easter egg hunt
here in container park
but this year it came with a little bit
of a twist
to celebrate the first holiday in a year
to have big events container park here
in las vegas made sure families are able
to have that easter fun
with an egg hunt but it's not your
traditional easter egg hunt
this one was touchless with the help of
the touchless egg hunt
app to make sure cover 19 protocols are
still in place
you had one hour to explore the park and
collect the eggs by scanning a code
through the app
a unique way to bring some holiday joy
back into our lives
i'm pretty glad that the community can
get together and we can all have fun
doing this egg hunt
and yeah it's pretty it's nice and it's
pretty fun we feel like it's
responsibility to have these type of
events especially on a holiday if you do
celebrate easter
for the downtown community in the local
while collecting eggs participants were
able to jam out to music with a silent
disco
and of course it wouldn't be easter
without a visit from the easter bunny
families were able to get pictures with
him after they collected their eggs
and sasha get this organizers tell me
that they expected 200 people to show up
but instead 400 people came out today
live in container park victoria saha
8 news now